สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะ
ขอต้อนรับทุกคนนะคะเข้าสู่ห้องเรียน
comprehensible ไยห้องเรียนภาษาไทยแบบ
ธรรมชาติใช่ค่ะเราต้องฟังเยอะๆค่ะเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยวันนี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กกับครูชิเ
เนี่ยมาพบกับนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะในวันนี้
วันอะไรคะครูช
วันนี้วันอังคารค่ะค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ 20
ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะ
กุมภาพันธ์นะปีคพ.ศเท่าไหร่คะ
พุทธศักราช
2567 ปีคริสตศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะ 2  0  2
4 ค่ะอ่าวันนี้ครูปุ๊กครูชิมาพบกับนัก
เรียนทุกคนนะคะในวันอังคารที่ 20 เดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพุทธศักราช
2567 ปีคริสตศักราชที่
2024 ค่ะ
อื้อหือแล้ววันนี้ค่ะตามสัญญาครูปุ๊กครู
ปุ๊กอืสัญญาครูปุ๊กสัญญาใช่มั้ยเราบอกว่า
เราจะเอาเกมมาท้าทายกันอีก
ออวันนี้มีเกมอีกแล้วโอ้โหใช่ค่ะแต่วัน
นี้เนี่ยไม่ใช่เป็นเกมจับผิดภาพแล้ว
นะนะวันนี้จะเป็นเกมทายเราเรียกอะไรนะทาย
คำอืนะมีภาพให้แล้วก็ให้คุณคิดว่านี่คือ
คำว่าอะไรอ่าอืมก็คือคำศัพท์ใช่่มั้ยมัน
จะเป็นคำศัพท์ภาษาไทยเนาะแต่มีรูปภาพให้
ดูอ่ายากมยูชิ
เอ้าอันนี้มันระดับเอ่อ beginner ชั้นสูง
แล้วใกล้ๆอินเทอร Media แล้วก็ต้องมีคำ
ศัพท์ยากๆเพิ่มมากขึ้น
โอ้โหเอาอย่างงี้มันนักเรียนอาจจะไม่รู้
คำศัพท์ก็ได้แต่ดูจากภาพเนี่ยนักเรียนอาจ
จะเอาคำมารวมกันได้
เออแล้วนักเรียนจะได้รู้ว่าภาษาไทยเนี่ย
มีคำที่เอาเอาคำศัพท์มาจากคำศัพท์ 2 คำ
ที่มันมันมันไม่เหมือนกันเลยพอมารวมกัน
ความหมายมันเปลี่ยนไปไงอืนะเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยนะคำ 2 คำพอมารวมกันเป็นคำใหม่เนาะ
มี 2 พยางค์แทนใช่มยใช่ครูชิยกตัวอย่างนะ
เช่นแม่อือ
ฮึใช่มั้ยเป็นผู้หญิงใช่มั้ยแม่อ้าอุ้ม
ลูกหน่อยนะกันมีลูกด้วยนะคะอ่าจะได้ลแม่
บี๋นะอืแม่แม่
อื
ออแม่บวก
ด้วยโหูชินักเรียนจะรู้มยว่ามันคืออะไร
ก๊อกน้ำอ่ะเออเออแแม่บวกน้ำนะเกิดคำใหม่
ขึ้นมาเป็นแม่น้ำนะแม่น้ำเห็นมแม่น้ำ
เจ้าพระยาแม่น้ำฮวงเหหแม่น้ำอะไรอีกคะ
แยงซีเกียงแม่น้ำเอ่อเจ้าเอ่อแม่น้ำโขง
เออนะมีแม่น้ำแม่น้ำใช่มยนะเอาคำ 2 คำคำ
ว่าแม่กับน้ำนะคำว่าแม่มี 1 ยางน้ำมี 1
พยางค์เอามารวมกันเป็นแม่น้ำเกิดเป็นคำ
ใหม่ 2 พยางค์แม่น้ำแล้วเป็นคำใหม่ที่มี
ความหมายใหม่แบบนี้อือืนะนักเรียนเพ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยลองเดาเอานะผิดถูกไม่เป็นไร
ใช่มั้ยคะไม่เป็นไรนะคะนักเรียนจะได้รู้
ว่าภาษาไทยก็มีการนำคำ 2 คำมารวมกันและมี
ความหมายใหม่อืนะคะนะ
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยมันไม่ใช่ว่าเอ้ยถ้าทาย
ผิดแล้วไอคิวไม่ดีใช่มยไม่มันมันมันเป็น
การเรียนภาษาอย่างหนึ่งและทำให้จำจำง่าย
จำง่ายอ่าแล้วก็สนุกด้วยใช่มยใช่ต้อง
เดาเราเริ่มกันเลยนะได้ภาพแรกค่ะ
อ่าภาพแรกเนี่ยมีเด็กภาพแรกมีเด็กเด็ก
เนี่ยไม่ได้หันหน้ามาโดยตรงๆ
นะหันหลังแล้วก็โชว์อะไรคะก้นค่ะก้นอ่า
โชว์ก้นก้นอยู่ตรงกูชินี่ค่ะก้นหน้าตี
นะโชว์ก้นให้ตีอือนะคะภาพที่ 2 เป็นรูป
อะไรคะหอยค่ะแต่อันนี้มีแต่เปลือกเนาะไม่
มีตัวน่าจะกินไปแล้วเปลือก
เห็น
มั้ยทายค่ะครูปุ๊กภาพที่ 1 ภาพที่ 2 ถ้า
บอกว่าภาพก้นเปลือกหอยก็ไม่ได้นะก้นหอย
เนี่ยอันเนี้ยมีความหมายค่ะนะในภาษาไทย
ก้นหอยใช่มั้ยปิ้งปองถูกต้องค่ะภาพนี้ก็
คือคำว่าก้นหอยนักเรียนรู้จักก้นหอยมั้ย
คะนี่ค่ะก้
อ่าลายนิ้วมือเราเนี่ยนะลายนิ้วมือเรามัน
จะมี 2 แบบเนาะที่เป็นแบบก้นหอยก็คือมัน
จะมีจุดตรงกลางนะแล้วก็วนๆๆออกมาจากจุด
ตรงกลางเนาะนะแต่บางอันเนี่ยมันจะไม่เป็น
ลายก้นหอย
ค่ะนะก็เลยเรียกลายนี้ว่าก้นหอยเพราะว่า
เหมือนก้นของหอยมูชิเหมือนค่ะเนี่ยถ้าเรา
ดูข้างในของหอยนะผ่ามาหอยมันก็จะเหมือน
กับวนน่ะอันนี้หอยนอติลุสนะมันก็จะวนออก
ข้างนอกไปเรื่อยๆนะคะหรือนักเรียนดูจาก
หอยจริงๆเนี่ยค่ะก้นหอยก็มีการวนแบบนี้
เหมือนกันเพราะฉะนั้นลวดลายอะไรที่มันวนๆ
แบบเนี้ยเราก็จะเรียกลายนั้นว่าลายก้นหอย
ง่ายเนอะภาษาไทยอื้อหือ
เช่นบางทีเนี่ยเอ่อคุณไปดูเอ่อคุณซื้อ
อะไรนะเสื้อเสื้อตัวนึงแล้วเสื้อเนี่ยมี
ลายม้วนๆนๆนเออครูชินึกถึงนึกถึงเอ่อยอม
นึกถึงอันนี้ครูปุ๊กอะไรเวลาเราไปที่
เชียงแสนใช่มั้ยเชียงแสนก็จะมีแจกันแบบ
นี้อแล้วแจกันก็จะมีลายแมวๆๆๆนี่เจ๊กัน
ของเชียงแสนก็จะมีลายก้นหอยค่ะอืมีลายก้น
หอยนะเป็นลายที่ในสมัยโบราณเนาะเขาก็ทำมา
ตั้งแต่เมื่อก้อนเมื่อก่อนนะก็ดูจากหอย
เนี่ยแหละแล้วก็เอามาทำเป็นลวดลายนะถูก
ต้องนะคะต่อมาค่ะภาพที่ 2 ภาพที่ 2 ภาพ
ที่ 2 เรียนช่วยกันช่วยกันเร็วเร็วๆ็ๆว่า
อะไรภาพแรกเป็นรูปอะไรคะเป็นรูปผู้ชาย
เนาะใส่หมวกแล้วก็มีต้นข้าวค่ะครูชิแล้ว
เค้าเนี่ยมีถือมือเนี่ยถือเคียวเห็นมยมือ
ซ้ายเนี่ยถือเคียวเป็นมีดชนิดนึงสำหรับ
เกี่ยวข้าวเนาะแล้วก็มีต้นข้าวเขาจับต้น
ข้าวอยู่ค่ะครูชิแล้วก็กำลังเอาเคียว
เนี่ยจะไปเกี่ยวแน่ๆเลยไปเกี่ยวข้าวค่ะ
ออหอันนี้ก็เป็นชาวนากำลังเกี่ยวข้าวภาพ
ที่ 2 อ่ะมีมือค่ะนะมือของเราเนี่ยมี 5
นิ้วนะนิ้วโป้งนิ้วชี้นิ้วกลางนิ้วนาง
นิ้วก้อยนะแล้วก็เค้าเนี่ยไม่ได้ยกมา 5
นิ้วนะคะครูชินะเยกมานิ้วเดียวใช่มยใช่
ค่ะเค้าเนี่ยยกนิ้วก้อยขึ้นขึ้มานิ้ว
เดียวส่วนนิ้วนางเนี่ยเา้าเก็บลงมาใช่มย
งอนลงมาแล้วก็นิ้วกลางนิ้วชี้แล้วก็นิ้ว
โป้งค่ะมันก็เลยเหลือนิ้วเดียวค่ะนิ้ว
ก้อย
อ้าข้าวก้อยอืไม่มีคำนี้ค่ะนะเออฟาร์ม
ฟาร์มข้าวไม่ใช่ฟาร์มข้าวชาว
นาไม่ใช่ชาวนาก้อยมันก็ไม่ได้ค่ะมันก็ไม่
มีคำนี้ค่ะครูชิ
อืมแต่มีอยู่คำนึงค่ะเพราะว่าเค้าใช้
เคียวเนี่ยเกี่ยวค่ะเกี่ยวนะเกี่ยวก็คือ
การตัดพอไปเกี่ยวเสร็จแล้วเราก็ตัดออกมา
นะมีคำนี้จริงๆมีคำว่าเกี่ยวก้อยนักเรียน
รู้จักเกี่ยวก้อยมั้ยคะเกี่ยวก้อยนี่ค่ะ
อ่าอันนี้เนี่ยน่าจะเป็นมือผู้ชายกับมือ
ผู้หญิงเนาะแล้วก็เดินอ่ะเป็นแฟนกัน
เดี๋ยวนี้เนี่ยจะเป็นผู้ชายผู้ชายผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงก็ได้เนาะนะเป็นแฟนกันเค้าก็เดิน
เกี่ยวก้อยกันค่ะนะดูน่ารักค่ะนะบางทีผู้
หญิงอาจจะแบบหรือผู้หญิงเนาะก็อาจจะแบบ
เดินเกี่ยวใก้กันหน่อยอ่าอืจะได้เข้าใจ
เนาะว่าเกี่ยวก้อยเป็นยังไงเอานิ้วก้อย
กับนิ้วก้อยเนี่ยเอามาเกี่ยวกันค่ะเกี่ยว
กันไว้อนี่ไม่ขาดเหมือนเกี่ยวข้าวนะคะ
อันนั้นนเกี่ยวแล้วก็ตัดไงอันนี้เกี่ยว
โดยไม่ต้องตัดแต่บางทีเนี่ยการเกี่ยวก้อย
มันเหมือนกับเป็นการสัญญาไงอือฮึอือเป็น
การแบบสัญญากันเราจะรักกันต่อไปนะคะสัญญา
แล้วก็มีคนอยากจะสัญญาก็เอากนิ้วก้อยมา
เกี่ยวกันเป็นการทำสัญญากันหรือตอนสมัย
เราเด็กๆเนาะเราเด็กๆเนี่ยเวลาเราโกรธกับ
เพื่อน
นะโกรธกันไม่ชอบกันแล้ว 1 วันเนี่ยเรามา
ดีกันนะเราจะเป็นเพื่อนกันต่อไปนะเราก็จะ
บอกว่าโอเคเราดีกัน
นะอืมถ้าแบบเพื่อนอยากดีด้วยเพื่อนก็จะ
ย้ามาโกรธทำไมล่ะคะไม่ดีเหรอคะเ้าอันนี้
ไม่ใช่ไลฟ์เหรอคะไม่ใช่ค่ะเด็กๆในไทย
เนี่ยเขาตอนเด็กๆเนาะเรามีเวลาเราไม่ชอบ
เราก็โกรธแล้วโป้งเลยโป้งโป้งเห็น
มั้มือเนี่ยแค่บิดแบบเนี้ยอันเนี้ยแปลว่า
โกรธโกรธไม่พูดด้วยนะคไม่ใช่หมายถึงว่า
ชอบแต่ถ้าเกิดไร้ชอบต้องอย่างนี้นะหัน
ด้านข้างหรือว่าเยี่ยมมากเยี่ยมมากเยี่ยม
มากก็จะแบบดีมากดีมากเยี่ยมมากก็จะแบบซ้ำ
ๆซๆแบบนี้ทำแบบนี้แต่ถ้าโกธเนี่จะยื่นไป
ข้างหน้าแล้วก็แบบให้เห็นนิ้วอย่างเดียว
นิ้วโป้งหน้าเนี่ยก็จะบอกไม่ชอบด้วยนะ
เด็กๆเนาะตัวแล้วไม่ค่อยไม่ทำแล้วเนาะ
อื้อหือโกรธอันนี้น่าจะเป็นถ้าเป็นผู้
ใหญ่ก็อาจจะแบบเล่นๆน่ะสนุกๆแบบโกรธแล้ว
อืดีกัน
นะนะถ้าดีก็เอามานิ้วก้อยมาเกี่ยวกันค่ะ
อือหือเกี่ยยวก้อยนะแปลว่าดีกันแล้วดีกัน
แล้วเห็นมยเพราะฉะนั้นการเกี่ยวก้อยเนี่ย
มีหลายความหมายความหมายว่ารักกันชอบกัน
สัญญานะคะพรุ่งนี้ฉันจะมาหาเธอแล้วก็จะมา
จริงๆนะสัญญาอือืหรือว่าดีกันใช่มั้ยใช่
ค่ะอ่ะอุ๊ยคำนี้น่าจะง่ายนะคะง่ายไปหรือ
เปล่านักเรียนน่าจะตอบได้ค่ะมันตรงตัวเลย
ค่ะนะโกหกอ้าไม่ใช่
โกซิกส์ยาวขึ้นใช่มั้ยคะเอาพินอคคิโอไง
พูดโกหกก็จมูกยาวขึ้นพูดโกหกอีกก็จมูกยาว
หรือมีสัญลักษณ์นะโกหกพูดไม่จริง
นะอันนี้เนี่ย
โกหกอแล้วเพราะว่าภาษาไทยอาจจะอ่านไม่ไม่
ตรงกับภาษาอังกฤษไงเสียงอาจจะไม่เหมือน
กันพิน็อกคิโอ
แต่คำนี้ดีนะครูปุ๊กโกหกเนี่ยมันทำให้นัก
เรียนจำง่ายดิเนี่ยพินอคคิโอก็ชอบโกหกนะ
ไม่รู้ชอบหรือเปล่าอาจจะไม่ได้ชอบแต่
เหมือนอยากจะแก้ตัวว่าตัวเองไม่ได้ทำหรือ
ว่านะแบบเหมือนปฏิเสธไม่อยากบอกว่าตัวเอง
ทำก็เลยโกหกกลัวความผิดแต่จริงๆอ่ะดู
นิทานเรื่องนี้นะคือตอนเด็กๆก็จะรู้สึก
ว่าการฟังเรื่องพิน็อกคิโอ
มันแค่แบบว่าคุณอย่าโกหกอืโกหกแล้วไม่ดี
ค่ะแต่แต่พอเราโตขึ้นแล้วเราดูเนี่ยเราจะ
รู้สึกเลยคำพูดบางคำที่นางฟ้าพูดนะคุณ
โกหกครั้งที่ 1 การโกหกครั้งที่ 1 มันจะ
ทำให้คุณต้องโกหกครั้งที่ 2 ครั้งที่ 3
ครั้งที่ 4 ไปเรื่อยๆใช่มั้ยเพราะอะไร
เพราะว่าเมื่อคุณโกหกครั้งที่ 1 คุณจะ
โกหกครั้งที่ 2 เพื่อให้ครั้งที่ 1 คน
เชื่อถูกต้องค่ะแล้วคุณก็ต้องมีการโกหก
ครั้งที่ 3 เพื่อที่จะให้คนเชื่อสิ่งที่
คุณโกหกผ่านๆมาอ่าสมมุติว่าครูปุ๊กเนี่ย
ขโมยของอะไรสักอย่างนึงของครูชิอ่ะสมมุติ
เป็นแว่นตาก็ได้นะไม่รู้อืนะหรือว่าเงิน
ดิครูพุกหน่าจะชอบเงินมากกว่าแว่น
ตาขโมยเงินเหายากไงเอเงินเงินมันจับยาก
ว่าเป็นของครูปุ๊กหรือของครูชิไงอ่าใช่
มั้ยเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยก็ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยขโมย
เงินครูชิอืนะทีนี้เนี่ยครูชิก็ต้องมาบอก
เอ๊ะสงสัยครูปุ๊กครูปุ๊กเนี่ยขโมยหรือ
เปล่า
นะน้องปุ๊กเมื่อวานเข้ามาในห้องพี่
อ่ะหยิบเงินไปมั้ยไม่ค่ะไม่ได้หยิบอะไรไป
เลยค่ะอ้าเงินพี่หายไปไหนไม่รู้อ่ะไม่รู้
นะใช่มเนี่ยวางอยู่บนโต๊ะเออ
30,000 วางไว้อยู่
ู้ไม่รู้ค่ะไม่ได้เอาไปไม่เคยไม่เห็นเลย
ตั้งแต่เข้าไปในห้องเนี่ยก็ไม่เห็นเงิน
แล้วนะพอครูปุ๊กโกหกครั้งที่ 1 ว่าครู
ปุ๊กเนี่ยไม่ได้เอาไปใช่มยแล้วครูปุ๊กก็
อาจจะอยากอยากให้ครูชิเชื่อต่อไปว่าไม่
ได้เอาไปจริงๆเมื่อวานเนี่ยเข้าไปแล้ว
เนี่ยออกมายังเจอกับน้องชายเลยนะออเหรอออ
ซึ่งจริงๆไม่ได้เจอใช่นะอแล้วพอเสร็จแล้ว
เนี่ยถ้าน้องชายบอกอ้าวไม่ได้ไปด้วยไม่
ได้เจออ้าเอเหรอ
อ๋อเจำคนผิดจำผิดมั้งหรือว่าเห็นผิดมั้ง
มันก็ต้องโกหกต่อไปอ่ะเพื่อให้โกหกของเรา
ครั้งที่ 1 เนี่ยมันสมบูรณ์หรือว่าถูก
ต้องหรือว่ามันมีอะไรมารองรับเนาะแล้ว
แล้วมันก็เลยเป็นความหมายดีที่ที่กูชิพูด
ถึงเ่ะพอเราดูหนังเยคำโกหกอ่ะมันมันจะ
เติบโตเร็วเหมือนเหมือต้นไม้ไงอือฮึตอน
เด็กๆอ่ะไม่เข้าใจว่าจมูกพินอคคิโอทำไม
กลายเป็นต้น
ไม้เพราะมันเป็นพิน็อกคิโอเป็นหุ่นไม้ไง
คุณดูชิกูปุ๊กลองดูดิในภาพอ่ะมันเป็นต้น
ไม้เสร็จแล้วมันก็มีใบแล้วมันก็มีกิ่ง
แล้วก็มีรังนกมันเริ่มแบบไปเรื่อยๆมัน
เริ่มแบบเติบโตอันนั้นหมายถึงว่ามันมันทำ
ให้ความหมายมันดีนะคือตอนเด็กๆเราดูแล้ว
ไม่เข้าใจถึงขนาดนั้นว่าเา้าบอกว่าการ
โกหกมันเหมือนกับมันจะเติบโตเร็วเหมือน
ต้นไม้ที่เติบโตนะ
เออแล้วก็มีเห็นมมีบเป็นต้น
ไม้มันจะไม่หยุดค่ะมันต้องเติบโตไปเรื่อย
ๆอืมเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยต้องต้องระวังการ
โกหกใช่ค่ะถ้าเราไม่โกหกทั้งตั้งแต่แรก
เราก็ไม่ต้องโกหกต่อไปต่อไปนะมันก็เลย
เป็นผิดแล้วผิดอีกผิดต่อไปครูชิว่าตอน
เนี้ยนักเรียนเใจคำว่าโกหกมากๆเพราะมีคำ
ว่าโกแล้วก็
หกเออคำศัพท์แบบนี้ก็ทำให้จำง่ายดีนะอือ
ฮึคำต่อไปค่ะครูปุ๊กอันเออภาพเนี้นัก
เรียนจะรู้จักมั้ยไม่รู้จักค่ะเด็กๆรุ่น
ใหม่ๆเขาก็อาจจะไม่รู้จักค่ะนะอันนี้เป็น
อุปกรณ์ที่เราเวลาเราไปจับปลานะเราก็จะ
ใส่ไปในเอ่อที่เก็บปลาเราเรียกว่าคล่อง
อ่าเพราะว่าข้างบนเนี่ยฝามันจะเป็นแบบจาก
ข้างบนนะเป็นไม้ค่ะไม้ไผ่แล้วก็สไลด์บางๆ
เนาแล้วก็เอามาถักทำให้แบบปลาเนี่ยมัน
ขึ้นไม่ได้มันเจ็บมันติดนะข้างบนจะใหญ่
แล้วข้างในมันจะเล็กเพราะว่าเขาจะสานกัน
ลักษณะแบบนี้นะกูชิช่วยสา
อ่าใช่ค่ะอันนี้ซูมข้างในค่ะเวลาเราใส่ลง
ไปเนี่ยใส่ได้ค่ะนะแต่แต่ว่าปลาจะออกมา
เนี่ยออกไม่ได้นะคือเค้าเรียกว่าตะข่อง
แต่บางบางทีเราก็เรียกสั้นๆว่า
คล่องนะเวลาใส่ปลาลงไปเนี่ยแล้วเค้าก็จะ
เอาไปแช่ในน้ำน้ำมันสามารถจะเข้าไปข้างใน
ได้ค่ะนะก็เป็นที่เก็บปลาไม่ให้ไม่ให้มัน
หนีนะไม่ได้ใส่เป็นกระป๋องพลาสติกอะไรแบบ
นี้ในสมัยก่อนเนี่ยนะไอคดีเนาะเราไม่ต้อง
ถือกระป๋องน้ำไปเราไม่
กระดดใช่มันอาจจะกระโดดกระโดดกระโดดหนี
ได้แต่ข้องเนี่ยปลามันดิ้นก็ไปไหนไม่ได้
เพราะมีฝาปิดล็อคเอาไว้ใช่ค่ะนะคำว่าอัน
ห้องใช่นะภาพที่ 2 อ่ะคะหัวใจค่ะนะเอามา
รวมกันเนี่ยเเอาคำเดียวเนอะข้อง
ใจ
น่าถูกต้องค่ะมีคำว่าข้องใจแล้วข้องใจแปล
ว่าอะไรอ่ะแปลว่าเอาหัวใจมาใส่ในข้องหนี
ไม่ได้ไม่ใช่ค่ะนะข่องเนี่ยมันมีแบบ
เหมือนข้องใจเนี่ยมันแปลว่าเราเนี่ยมี
ความสงสัยค่ะยังคิดอยู่
เอ๊จริงหรอข้องใจอ่ะูชิวางเงินไว้ 3
30,000 จริงๆเหรอ
อืเมื่อกี้หยิบมามันแค่หมื่นเดียว
นะข้องใจ 30,000 เห็นอยู่แค่หมื่นเดียว
ที่เรา
หยิบก็เลยใจสงสอ่าไม่รู้ใครโกหกเออใช่มย
เรามีความสงสัยเหมือนบางทีเนี่ยเอ่อแฟน
โทรมาบอกว่าออมากินข้าวด้วยไม่ได้นะต้อง
ไปธุระไปเราก็จะเอ๊ธุระทำไมไม่บอกว่าธุระ
อะไรก็จะมีความข้องใจเอ๊ไปไหนนะอืนะเนี้ย
ข้องใจนะบางคนเนี่ยข้องใจแล้วก็ถามใช่มย
บางคเนี่ยค้องใจแล้วไม่ถามค่ะปล่อยให้ตัว
เองสงสัยแล้วก็คิดเยอะ
ค่ะคิด
เยอะแต่นักเรียนต้องระวังนะข้องใจกับขัด
ใจมันคนละความหมายกันถูกมยข้องใจเราสงสัย
ขัดใจเนี่ยก็คือไม่ทำตามคนอื่นอืนะทำอยาก
ได้อือยากอยากกินเค้กอ่ะกูอยากกินเค้กต
นั้น
น่ะไม่ให้ไม่ต้องกินหรอกเดี๋ยว
อ้วนขัดใจ
มากขัดใจมากมากอันนี้ขัดใจไม่ใช่ข้องใจนะ
ใช่เหมือนเวลาแฟนบอกว่าวันนี้จะไป
ช้อปปิ้งนะคะไปด้วยกันนะแฟนบอกไปทำไมนัก
หนาใช่มโไม่ต้องไปหรอกเดินทำไมเยอะแยะของ
ก็มีเยอะแยะและเสื้อผ้าก็มีเต็มตู้เลยจะ
ไปซื้ออะไรอีกอ่าอันเนี้ยกไก่ข้องใจขอไ่
ขัดใจอะไรคะนักเรียนกไก่หรือข
ไ่ปิง
ตยขัดใจค่ะเราอยากทำแล้วเไม่ให้ทำอย่าง
เงี้ยมันขัดใจใช่มั้ยอือันนี้จะทำให้โกรธ
เหมือนกันค่ะ
นะแต่ถ้าข้องใจเนี่ยหมายถึงมีปัญหาที่เรา
คิดไม่ออกมีความสงสัยแล้วก็อยากจะรู้มัน
แบบอื้อหือทำไมทำไมทำไมทำไมทำไมมันจะมี
ความรู้สึกว่าทำไมมันเป็นแบบนี้นะอ่าแล้ว
บางคนจะหาคำตอบมาเยอะแยะไปหมด
เลยทำไมแฟนยังไม่กลับโอ้โหไปเที่ยวไปหา
ผู้หญิงใหม่หรือเปล่าไปทำงานมั้ยไปทำนี้
ไม่คิดดีๆคะอไม่ได้ค่ะทำงานโอทำทำ OT
เพื่อที่จะหาเงินเยอะๆมาให้เราใช้เอ่อ
สามีทำงานหนักน่าจะเหนื่อยป่านนี้จะได้
กินข้าวหรือยัง
อืทำไมไม่คิดดีๆคะไม่ค่ะส่วนมากคนจะคิด
ไม่ดีไว้ก่อนค่ะถ้ามีเรื่องข้องใจใช่มั้ย
ใช่นะส่วนว่ากถ้าข้องใจเนี่ยก็คือจะเป็น
ปัญหาที่เรารู้สึกว่ามันไม่น่าใช่อ่ะบอก
ว่าทำงานงานจริงหรือเปล่าอะไรอย่างเงี้ย
คำต่อไปดีกว่าค่ะกูปุ๊กค่ะคำต่อไปโอ๊ะโอ
อ้าวโอ้โหอันนี้ง่าย
ค่ะภาพที่ 1 เป็นรูปขันขันน้ำาที่ 2 เป็น
รูปรูปหมากค่ะเป็นปานิดนึงหมากที่เอาไป
กินกับูที่สมัยก่อนเขาจะ
เคี้ยวแล้วก็มีน้ำสีแดงๆบ้วนออกมาเนาะ
เคี้ยวหมากนะแต่ว่าจริงๆไม่ใช่หมากอย่าง
เดียวมีพลูมีปูนทาสีสีแบบ
ส้มๆน่านะก็เวลาเา้าเคี้ยวไปเคี้ยวมามัน
ก็นะน้ำหมากน่ะมันจะออกมาเป็นสีแดงๆงแล้ว
ก็บ้วนทิ้งแล้วก็ฟันก็จะสีดำค่ะแล้วคำว่า
ขันหมากมันคืออะไรค่ะขันหขันหกนะขันหกก็
หมายถึงว่าเวลาผู้ชายเนี่ยจะไปสู่ขอผู้
หญิงใช่มยคือไปตกลงแล้วคุยแล้วว่าคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่เนี่ยอยากได้เงินสินสอดเท่าไหร่น่า
แล้วก็ตกลงก็จะแต่งงานกันวันไหนก็จะยก
ขบวนขันหมากเนี่ยมารับตัวเจ้าสาวค่ะรับ
ตัวผู้หญิงที่เป็นเจคะอืนักเรียนมีพานที่
ใส่หมากด้วยจริงๆเพราะว่าเพราะว่าคนสมัย
ก่อนใส่หมากเอ่อคนสมัยก่อนที่ครูปุ๊กเล่า
ให้ฟังคือกินหมากเพราะฉะนั้นเวลาจะไปขอ
สาวๆก็ต้องเอาหมากไปฝากผู้ใหญ่ใช่มยมีธูป
เทียนแพนะคะธูปแล้วก็เทียนใช่มเทียนอยู่
ข้างล่างธูปเทียนเนี่ยเป็นการแสดงความ
เคารพนะคะมีแหวนที่จะไปขอมั่นผู้หญิงมัน
ต้องเริ่มจากมั่นก่อนนะแล้วก็แต่งนะแล้ว
ก็มีเงินเงินเหล่านี้เราเรียกว่าสินสอด
สินสอดคือเงินที่ให้กับพ่อแม่ผู้หญิงนะค
ให้แบบให้ให้ปอ่ะให้สำหรับขอบคุณครับ
เลี้ยงภรรยาผมจนโตขนาดนี้ตอนนี้ผมขอนะนะ
แล้วก็มีกล่องข้างล่างน่าจะเป็นทองนะทอง
ส้อยทองอ่าหรืออาจจะเป็นเป็นสร้อยเป็น
แหวนเป็นกำไรข้อมืออะไรแบบนี้เนาะนะก็เรา
เรียกว่าสินสอดอง
ั้นใช่ค่ะแล้วทั้งหมดนี้เราเรียกว่าขัน
หมากเหมือนกับที่เวลาที่เอ่อคนจะแต่งงาน
ถ้านักเรียนมาประเทศไทยอาจจะเคยได้ยินเขา
จะมีกล้วยนะมีต้นกล้วยต้นอ้อยแล้วก็เดิน
ขบวนแบบนี้ค่ะมีมีเจ้า
เบ่ามีมีเจ้าบ่านะคะเจ้าเบ่าก็คือผู้ชาย
ที่จะไปแต่งงานกับผู้หญิงมีเถ้าแก่ก็คือ
ผู้ใหญ่ที่จะไปขอผู้หญิงนั่นแหละแล้วก็มี
ต้นกล้วยที่แสดงถึงแบบลูกเยอะๆต้นอ้อย
แสดงความหวานนะต่อไปก็จะเป็นอาหารให้กับ
ครอบครัวนี้แล้วด้านหลังเห็นมั้ยคะก็มี
ถือพานขันหมากถือขนมถืออาหารแล้วด้านหลัง
ก็จะมีโหฮิโอโอ
โอตึง
ตึงม่องเทงม่องเทงม่งเทงม่งม่งเทงมงเทงมง
เทงม่งเคมีมะกรูดมะแลกมะ
น้ำเห็นมอันนี้ขันหมากค่ะอันนี้จะเป็น
ขบวนค่ะขบวนขันหมาก
ยกไปเพื่อขอผู้หญิงนะไปรับตัวเจ้าสาวเลย
นะขบวนขันหมากเาเรียกขันหมากค่ะนะแล้วก็
ได้อีกคำมั้ยคะนั่นน่ะสิอ่ะไหนคะเอาอีก
ซักคำนะอ่าได้อันนี้อธิบาย
ยากเปลี่ยนคำใหม่ได้มยคะอ่ะไม่เป็นไรค่ะ
อันนี้ในรูปแรกเนี่ยเป็นแก้วแต่แก้วเนี่ย
แตกค่ะอือแตกแล้วแล้วรูปที่ 2 เป็นพาลนะ
เค้าเรียกว่าแตกพานนะโอ้โหแตกพาลนี่มันมี
ความหมายเหมือนกับคือผู้ชายที่เป็นเด็กๆ
อ่ะกำลังเป็นเด็กอยู่กำลังแบบเริ่มโต
เนี่ยก็จะมีหน้าอกแบบเริ่มใหญ่เริ่มแบบมี
กล้ามเริ่มมีหนวดเริ่มมีลูกกระเดือก
แตกพานก็หมายถึงวัยรุ่นเนาะที่กำลัง
เปลี่ยนฮอร์โมนกำลังเปลี่ยนนะมีสิวบ้างมี
แบบอื้อหือมีหนวดเริ่มขึ้นแบบนะก็
อันเนี้ยมันแสดงถึงความเป็นวัยรุ่นที่
กำลังจะเข้าเป็นผู้ใหญ่เหมือนเด็กเป็นผู้
ใหญ่เป็นหนุ่มเป็นหนุ่มเป็นหนุ่มนะอเป็น
หนุ่มแล้วเป็นหนุ่มแล้วเนี่ยเค้าเรียกว่า
โอ้โหแตกพานเลยเหมือนแบบเนื้อเ๊ๆ
เริ่มเป็นผู้ใหญ่แล้วเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ย
สามารถแบบมีมีภรรยาได้เออหรือว่าบางทีเ้า
บอกว่าแตกเนื้อหนุ่มนะแตกเนื้อหนุ่มเพราะ
ว่าร่างกายเนี่ยมันจะเปลี่ยนไงนะแบบสวัดี
ครับอ่าหรือผู้หญิงก็แตกเนื้อสาวนะก็นะ
มันก็แบบเหมือนรูปร่างก็จะเปลี่ยนนะด้วย
ฮอร์โมนเนาะนะนี่ก็แต่คำว่าแตกพานเราใช้
ใช้แต่กับผู้ชายนะคะนักเรียนไม่ใช้กับผู้
หญิงนะผู้หญิงบอกแตกเนื้อสาวได้ผู้ชายบอก
แตกพานหรือแตกแตกเนื้อหนุ่มได้อนะคะก็คือ
ทุกอย่างจะฮอร์โมนเปลี่ยนมีขนมีมีหนวดมี
เามีลูกกระเดือกแล้วเสียงก็เปลี่ยนจาก
สวัสดีแม่ก็เป็นสวัสดี
แม่เ้ยผมเป็นอะไรอ่ะอ่านะก็อันนี้เนี่ย
ตอนนี้เนี่ยมันไม่ค่อยมีคนใช้แล้วนะูชิ
ส่วนมากเจะไปแตกเนื้อหนุ่มแตกเนื้อสาวกัน
มากกว่านะแต่ว่าก็ให้รู้คำศัพท์ไว้เนอะนะ
แตกพาลเนี่ยนะก็ในความหมายนะเด็กๆที่
กำลังจะเป็นวัยรุ่น
ค่ะอือหือนะคะจริงๆเราก็ยังมีอีกนะไม่
เป็นไรเอาไว้โอกาสหน้าเรามาคุยแล้วก็มา
เล่นเกมแบบนี้กันใหม่เพื่อให้นักเรียนจำ
คำที่แบบคำภาษาไทยที่มาจากคำ 2 คำมารวม
กันและได้เป็นความหมายใหม่นะคะค่ะนะวัน
นี้เนี่ยหมดเวลาแล้วเราก็ต้องลานักเรียน
ไปก่อนแต่ไม่ใช่ลาไปเลยจะกลับมาพบกันใหม่
ค่ะลาแล้วไม่ใช่ลาก่อนหรือไม่ได้ลาจากนะ
ก็วันนี้ขอบคุณค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
ค่ะ